you were an agent for how long what was
the uh going on 20 years you were a CIA
agent for 20 years covert operations
office right so you were a this was your
job this was not like a person's using
somebody in media to say hey we want you
to kind of help us out with some
information right no this is what you
did for a living okay and when you were
in what year to what year were you in
what were the what were the years you
served
um I was in I got out uh
around 2000 or so so 1980 to 2000 give
or take yeah okay so during those years
Facebook comes out of no four okay I
think Myspace is O3 O2 I don't know the
exact year but it's around the same time
can you check to see when Myspace came
out so social media wasn't really fully
around no from 1980 to 2000. so during
that time when you guys are working on
Ops and you're worried about China or
Russia or what they're doing what were
some of those threats then that you know
they use to you know inject their
propaganda and their beliefs we've all
seen what that Russian operative what's
his name Boris you know when he says
well the disinformation and they use
this and they use that what were some of
the fears and concerns you have when you
saw how they attacked us yeah I mean
this has been going on forever it's a
great a great point that you're you're
racing the technology has made it easier
right to influence people to to to get
your ideas out there
um so if you think about
go all the way back to World War II
right before uh Hitler invaded Russia
um then they were allies right so what
was Russia busy doing they were busy
trying to influence and and Germany to
some degree as well trying to influence
U.S public opinion at the time it was
very sort of uh isolationist at the
point so the the Russian agents were
here they were influencing trade unions
they were buying journalists right to
print articles they were setting up fake
associations right that would push
isolationism so it was a it was a more
laborious process in a way those things
are still done right but the technology
has just sped the ability to do that to
influence so if you're trying to
influence the population of a small
country to overthrow it to get rid of
some despotic dictator for instance uh
in the old days it was a long-term
covert action campaign right and and
now you've just got so so many options
right and people have I think something
else that's happened is again this idea
that because every generation wants it
to be easier for their own kids right
eventually you get the diminishing
returns and by that I mean you know
naturally my father wanted it to be
easier for me his father you know wanted
to be easier for him I want it to be
easier for my kids well eventually you
get to this point
where it becomes so uh soft right you
you could you can have the that
goes on around us right because we're
not worried about going out and finding
clean water and collecting food and and
you know it's it's I don't know maybe
that theory is completely off but that's
where I'm I'm going so so they would buy
let's just say journalists that's
working on New York Times or they will
buy journalists that work in at a major
paper that was one of their ways and
then hey write this or influence this
and that was their way to getting to the
people yeah you would look for you would
uh typically it would be a a sort of a
broader campaign you wouldn't say just
one right I mean and you operate on a
lot of different levels like this is
nothing new I'm not you know
this is Mike how would they make sure
that they wouldn't whistleblower say
anything
why how would they make sure the
journalists wouldn't come out and say I
just got approached by this and they're
paying me this much money I just want to
come out and tell here's what I've been
doing it's the same way you would go out
and say I want to I'm going to you know
recruit some asset right you have to you
have to ensure that you understand what
their motivations are right it's the
same thing right so you know that's why
you wouldn't go after somebody you know
who would be a leading journalist of
their day right because they've in in
today's world right you've got somebody
who's got you know 10 million followers
you know and so you're not going to
necessarily do that you're going to do
it a more subtle way which is what the
technology allows you to do right it
allows you to put it in there in various
ways and people watch something on Tick
Tock and their first thought is not this
is probably disinformation or I wonder
if somebody's paying for this campaign
yeah it's would it be easier to be a CI
agent today or during your time meaning
the tools the tools are the tools are
the tools they're always going to what
the tools are going to evolve and
they're going to change and they're
going to be here and they're going to
move on is it harder to be an agent
today to catch or is it easier to find
their fingerprints in different places
and kind of work it backwards yeah
that's it's it's it's easier today in
certain ways right you're not you're not
walking around in the middle of some you
know uh trying to figure out
where the hell you are using a map and a
compass shooting an Azimuth you know I
mean it's just like so you're just like
looking at your phone going oh we're
right here you know we're half a click
away from the Target and in in the old
days you'd be like God I don't know
where the hell we are because I don't
want to make it sound overly simplistic
but there's some truth to that and or
you're stomping around you know
someplace looking for a phone that
actually works right because you're in
some place that's you know difficult a
challenging environment now you got to
figure out where is there a a phone I
can actually this is actually Payphone
Payphone yeah remember those days and so
but uh
in other ways it hasn't really changed
because in other ways
the key to intelligence right whether
you're talking about U.S intelligence
Community are you talking about the
Brits or anyone out there or our
adversaries the key is the human Source
right I mean the the technology has
improved in terms of your collection of
technical information right you know
we've got satellites up there floating
around right I mean there's China has
this you know program trying to capture
all the data off our satellites you know
we talk about is you know space can
become weaponized it already is okay I
didn't even say that and so but at the
core of intelligence is the human right
and and that really hasn't changed that
much right identifying who's got access
to something who's possibly motivated to
talk to you and why you know that's
probably never gonna what would the
profile of people that could be uh uh
bot like and what I mean by that is when
you want to get somebody that uh has
given us until and is becoming a spy for
us you're getting somebody from Russia
that's giving us feedback of what
they're doing what profile would you
look at to see this guy could be a good
asset for us yeah yeah I mean I would
argue that in places like China or
places like Russia it can be easier
because you've got more opportunity
right they're living in a a in a
you know it's
you've got more Avenues of attack right
in a place like the US where
you know you still have you still have
your Traders unfortunately people like
James Nicholson and edley Hansen and or
uh sorry uh Hansen and edley Howard and
and uh Alder James and all these guys so
you still have people like that but it
is a little bit easier I think to Target
people who are living under the thumb of
a regime
um because you can point out the obvious
you know to some degree but typically
ideology and you know and there's been a
lot written about all of this and and
the techniques for recruitment so I'm
not again this is not sources and
methods but
um you know typically ideology is not
the the driver right it's something else
it's something more personal it's maybe
it's something as base as money maybe
it's they don't feel like they got
enough hugs right A lot of times they
feel disrespected right and you're
saying ideology is not the number one
motivation yeah typically not an asset
yeah when you when you think about the
the biggest cats I mean and that's
although that's you know some of the the
best Russian sources we've had over the
years again not nothing new this stuff's
been out there is uh you know they have
been based on ideology but for the most
part it's something else their kid is
sick and they need access to health care
or something whatever it may be and it
could be very pedestrian as a reason but
you have to look for those things and
again I guess the point being going back
to the original point is is that the
technology helps to speed things along
sometimes but underlying that you know
you still you need somebody you can
collect all the information you know
remotely and through intercepts that you
you want but you need somebody standing
in that tent who can then tell you what
everybody looked like when they made
this decision right or what would they
actually thinking yeah because like I
was in the I was in the United States
Air Force had a nuclear missile base
what was my first uh my first assignment
and to get my clearance I'll never
forget I go home uh and I'm at the mall
in my town and my fifth grade module I'm
19 at this point my fifth grade math
teacher Mr Bonaparte big buff he was a
football player black guy he was like oh
Shauna I'm like hey Mr Bonaparte we have
a moment he's like what the hell are you
doing and I'm like what do you mean he's
like the somebody in the government
called me I'm not even joking and they
asked me if I thought that you as a
child would grow up to do anything to
like sabotage or do something against
the country and I'm like what he's like
yeah he's like good luck whatever the
hell you're doing
I'm not I can't make this up and I was
like whoa that's just part of the
vetting process that's for the airport
going to my point you're talking about
technology so like when you have like
it's easier I I'm guessing for their
like digital profile like a Mark
Zuckerberg with Facebook that must have
been the CIA and the government's just
like oh my God people have been fighting
to keep this information now you're just
giving it because it's cool to do that
helps yeah well it does oh I mean look
you know I run a company that you know
private sector business that does
intelligence and investigations and due
diligence and the amount of information
that's available out there on the
average citizen not not just here in the
US but around the world for the most
part uh it's astonishing compared to 20
years ago you know 30 years ago for for
sure but uh it's it you know it's again
it's a uniquely American mindset which
is it's the government I got to worry
about no it's not it's the it's the
private business or the private sector
that's been hoovering up all this
information that you've been gleefully
happily giving them let me tell you
something Mike yeah a generation ago you
could literally have a family in the
next town over and your family would not
know okay now if you look at another
girl's story on Instagram your salute
CIA girlfriend will find you in less
than 24 hours
that's like speaking from experience 100
not speaking from experience I love you
babe no but it's it's so true that that
technology has sped up everything in our
lives for good and for bad yeah and I
might just really fast not to go up so a
lot of people get uh confused when it
comes to agent CIA agent which you were
to assets and my question is when it
comes to like an asset is there an
expiration date on that person like
let's say you use them on a mission are
they just on standby for future or is it
kind of like no good luck goodbye yeah
terminology always was always uh trips
people up you're right
um it's not so much agent
um you know it's officer got you don't
know why got you um asset you're right
is the the the the target not the
individual agent is typically law
enforcement for the most part
um and there is a difference yeah
there's a difference between law
enforcement recruitment of of assets or
sources an Intel Community right and
this is kind of goes across the board
it's not just I don't think it's from my
experience it's not just in the US is
that
you know you tend to from an Intel
perspective you tend to look at assets
for long term because you never know
where they're going to end up right law
enforcement for good reason sometimes
it's a you know it's a project specific
or a case-specific you know recruitment
or development of a source and then boom
you're gone right or you or you need to
burn the source because you're moving
towards you know the courts so there's
there is a big difference there
um but you know human nature being what
it is I don't know that motivations have
changed that much right I think
attention spans have shortened but I
don't think motivations have changed
that much for for people so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]